écoutez bonjour à tous ça fait plaisir
de vous retrouver sous souhaite à mon
tour une très belle année 2010 est fait
évidemment de victoire pour notre
candidat françois fillon à l'élection
présidentielle mais aussi deux victoires
pour vous qui seraient nos candidats aux
élections législatives
sans oublier bien évidemment les
élections sénatoriales au mois de
septembre
alors monsieur le président du conseil
national chez un sheikh lucquin s'il me
donner la parole je salue bien
évidemment bernard acoyer toute l'équipe
dirigeante et puis un salut spéciale
également à gérard larcher président du
sénat qui est toujours présent avec
bruno retailleau et l'ensemble de mes
collègues et amis parlementaires
alors en ce qui concerne le budget alors
est ce que ça marche
voilà ça y est quelques mots tout
d'abord évidemment du budget 2016
alors je suis allé un petit temps d
voilà donc vous avez le budget dans la
bonne nouvelle en ce qui concerne le
budget 2007 c'est que nous parvenons à
dégager un excédent budgétaire de 9,9
millions d'euros c'est grâce à vous
merci en augmentation de 48% par rapport
à 2015 est en augmentation de 141 % par
rapport aux prévisions budgétaires 2016
alors comment étant parvenu à cet
excédent budgétaire
vous allez me dire c'est la primaire je
dirais non puisque en fait l'argent la
primaire va aux candidats
malheureusement pas au parti donc ce
redressement à cet excédent budgétaire
il est dû à vous et rien qu'à vous alors
comment étant parvenu à ce bon résultat
et bien tout d'abord par la maîtrise des
dépenses de fonctionnement et je veux
vous remercier je veux remercier les
présidents départementaux secrétaires
départementaux les trésoriers
départementaux mais aussi toute l'équipe
nationale puisque nous sommes parvenus
à poursuivre notre politique d'économies
par la maîtrise des dépenses de
fonctionnement puisque nous avons fait
un million d'euros d'économies sur le
budget de fonctionnement
l'année dernière merci à vous et le
trésor national a montré l'exemple ce
que depuis deux ans que je suis
trésorier je ne me suis pas fait
rembourser un centime d'euros voilà
parce que je crois que quand on a une
responsabilité faut savoir montrer
l'exemple
on est parvenu à ce bon résultat à grâce
au maintien global des recettes dans un
contexte politique compliquée avec des
revenus liés aux cotisations des élus
très largement supérieur à ce qui était
prévu au budget et ça c'est un point où
vous savez c'est l'un de mes combats que
je mène avec vous j'estime que quand on
est élu des républicains on le doit au
parti on le doit aux militants et
naturellement on doit payer ses
cotisations des deux tiers des
cotisations revenant d'ailleurs aux
fédérations depuis drake nous avons noté
il y a deux ans donc tous les élus
doivent payer leurs cotisations sans
exception on n'y est pas encore mais on
y arrive tout doucement
et là vous avez les résultats concrets
dans votre budget 2016 du travail qui a
été fait depuis deux ans puisque en 2014
il avait un million six seulement de
recettes pour les cotisations des élus
et deux ans après en 2016 nous sommes à
trois millions 2 nous avons doublé les
recettes liées aux cotisations des élus
merci aux élus qui maintenant
remplissent leurs obligations à l'égard
du mouvement
le succès financier la primaire a permis
alors marginalement 2 millions de
recettes supplémentaires puisque ans
trésorier très prudent j'avais prévu 5
millions d'euros de prêts à la primaire
de récupérer 3 millions nous avons
récupéré des 5 millions sur les 5
millions et donc ça ne fait 2 millions
de recettes supplémentaires
et puis le contexte politique de l'année
a permis aussi de limiter les dépenses
d'action politique du parti notamment en
fin d'année de 2,3 millions d'euros le
budget à 2016 donc aura
permis à la fois l'organisation de la
primaire parce que nous avons prêté 5
millions d'euros à la primaire sans
lesquels la première n'aurait pas eu
lieu
le budget 2016 a permis de poursuivre le
désendettement du mouvement et il a
dégagé cet excédent sur lesquels nous
pouvons construire le budget 2010 est
alors en ce qui concerne le budget 2010
est c'est un budget qui va se
caractériser par la poursuite des
efforts engagés précédemment la maîtrise
des dépenses
c'est la condition sine qua none pour le
redressement du parti avant d'entamer le
redressement la france la stimulation
des recettes la poursuite du
désendettement du parti et le
financement d'actions politiques 2017
en ce qui concerne les dépenses de
fonctionnement
je vous propose pour le budget 2010 est
des dépenses en baisse par rapport au
budget 2016
non pas qu'ils veulent en faire moins de
choses mais simplement nous allons mieux
gérer le parti y as tombe de contrats
que nous allons renégocier course en
cours de renégociation
par exemple les prestations de
communication ou les prestations
informatiques et ça va nous permettre
donc tout en nous déployons comme nous
sommes déployés en 2016 de faire des
économies dans le budget de 2010 est les
recettes stimuler avec des dons
nationaux avec un objectif de 7 5
millions d'euros en forte progression
mais c'est l'effet positif attendu de la
victoire de françois fillon à la
primaire et da victoire de françois
fillon à l'élection présidentielle j'en
suis absolument certain bien évidemment
les adhésions aussi qu'ils ont augmenté
d'ailleurs on le ressent à que ce soit
les dons les adhésions en ce début
d'année 2010 est on a vu un bon les
adhésions et des dons et c'est très
encourageant les cotisations des élus
bien évidemment qu'ils vont continuer à
rentrer en 2017 alors à ce sujet j'ai
fait un point jean françois lamour
il faut que les choses soient claires et
le son dans le cadre de nos statuts on
ne peut pas être investi par le parti si
on n'est pas à jour de cotisation alors
les candidats qui vont être présentés ce
matin
le sont presque tous presque tous alors
moi je veux que les choses soient
claires je le dis en accord avec bernard
acoyer et avec jean françois lamour et
luc chatel ceux qui ne sont pas encore
ils ont jusqu'à la fin de ce mois 31
janvier pour se mettre en conformité
mais ceux qui seront investis ce matin
qu'ils ne seront pas encore fort mythe
et qui seront pas à jour de cotisation
au 31 janvier 2017 se verront retirer
leur investiture parce que c'est comme
ça au sein des républicains quand on est
investi quand on a la confiance d'une
partie
on doit se mettre en règle avec le parti
voilà il s'agissant des recettes
stimuler je profite j'en profite pour
refaire passer ce message vous savez que
les choses maintenant sont claires pour
toutes les adhésions et les cotisations
des élus
c'est un tiers pour le siège national et
deux tiers pour vous à chaque fois que
vous faites une adhésion renouvellement
aux nouvelles adhésions à chaque fois
vous fait payer un élu vous récupérez
les deux tiers pour faire fonctionner
vos fédérations c'est vrai que j'ai mise
en place il ya un peu plus d'un an qu'il
faut bien avoir en tête parce que
évidemment c'est une motivation
supplémentaire pour faire entrer les
adhésions et les cotisations des élus
pour poursuivre le désendettement du
parti en 2017 nous allons poursuivre le
remboursement de la dette
alors vous avez là un schéma qui est
très claire en 2014 nous avions une
dette de 74,5 millions d'euros nous
avons progressivement réduit en 2015 en
2016 la dette est ajourd'hui de 62,4
millions d'euros et à fin d'année 2010
est quand nous aurons remboursé cinq
millions et demi d'euros au pool
bancaire poursuivi leur remboursement de
notre dette auprès du groupe à
l'assemblée nationale et commencer le
remboursement la dette immobilière c'est
la sci nous serons à la fin d'année 2010
est à une dette de 54,9 millions d'euros
et c'est une bonne nouvelle puisque
c'est exactement la valeur de notre
siège donc nous avons en deux ans
rembourser 20 millions d'euros redresser
financièrement notre parti
et retrouver la confiance des banques
des militants et des français tout cela
va permettre le financement de l'action
politique
alors ce qu'il faut retenir sur ce point
c'est que nous avons pu donc grâce à
l'excédent 2016 grâce à cette bonne
gestion nous avons pu dégager une
enveloppe de 7 5 millions d'euros
destinés aux actions politiques pour les
élections présidentielle et législatives
je sais qu'il ya de nombreux candidats
aux élections initiative qui m'ont
interrogé est ce que nous serons aidés
que nous l'avons été les années
précédentes je n'ai pas voulu répondre à
cette question parce que je n'avais pas
de visibilité suffisante sur les
résultats de l'année 2016 et sur le
budget de 2010 7 mai il a été décidé
lors du comité politique présidé par
gérard larcher cette semaine aux parties
il a été décidé c'est une bonne nouvelle
2 consacré sur 7 7 5 millions d'euros 3
millions d'euros pour les élections
législatives et donc chacun des
candidats c'est la bonne nouvelle que
vous annoncer ce matin
chaque candidat chacun des candidats aux
élections législatives recevra six mille
euros pour pouvoir financer sa campagne
le parti est en ordre de marche et le
parti est à nouveau capacité de vous
aider pour gagner l'élection
présidentielle il faut gagner les
élections légistatives en conclusion le
budget 2010 est est construit sur les
grands équilibres suivant des coûts de
structure de 16,6 millions d'euros
intégralement couverts par la notation
l'état de 18,6 millions d'euros des
dépenses d'action politique financé par
les autres recettes du parti le budget
2010 est se caractérise par des coûts de
structure maîtrisés des prévisions de
recettes raisonnable des dépenses
d'action politique qui vont permettre de
nous mobiliser une situation financière
qui ont ils se rétablir et seniors grâce
à la poursuite de notre désendettement
j'aurais remercier bien évidemment
françois fillon remercier également
nicolas sarkozy grâce à qui nous avons
pu
redresser le parti remercier leur en
bouquet également remercié bernard
acoyer gérard larcher les membres du
comité financier le bureau politique la
direction du parti les militants vous
tous qui vous battez quotidiennement
pour faire vivre notre mouvement avec
évidemment dans la transparence qu'ils
aient présenté ce matin vous recevrez
tous et il sera transmis mais évidemment
à la presse parce que je pense qu'en
matière financière
il faut que nous soyons parfaitement
transparent et cher ami après avoir
redressé le parti regrets sur la france
avec françois fillon en avant pour la
victoire
merci merci mon cher daniel je veux
avant de procéder au vote je voudrais
saluer les différentes personnalités qui
nous ont rejoints laurent wauquiez vice
président des républicains président de
la région rhône alpes auvergne
bruno retailleau président du groupe
parlementaire au sénat
virginie calmels d'un membre du comité
politique de françois fillon valérie
boyer porte-parole des républicains et
de nombreux parlementaires mes chers
amis je vais vous faire travailler je
vais vous demander de sortir le petit
carton qui figurait votre dossier vous
avez un carton avec deux faces la bleue
et la grise si vous souhaitez adopter ce
budget je vais vous demander de lever la
partie bleu bleu tourné vers mon côté la
partie bleue de votre carton si vous
souhaitez en rejeter ce budget je vous
demanderais de mettre en avant la partie
grise de ce carton je vous demande donc
d'approuver le budget présenté par nos
trésorier national daniel fasquelle
on passe au vote
eh bien écoutez merci pour votre
fidélité votre confiance en daniel
fasquelle le budget donc adopté
[Applaudissements]